foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Madison
I'll go check
hey hey so I thought you said you
invited like 10 people oh no I invited a
ton oh wait camera snow shows babe I'm
probably six people's depressing I might
appearance that hate me
what's up Madison's mom
she's going through a divorce be nice
seriously this is a sweet 16. it's a big
deal yeah for sash I think Skeletor over
there must be the DJ can you tell him
where to set up yeah hey drains body you
got any glitch going sweet is that my
boombox
yeah
is that my auxiliary cord yeah
oh you want my phone
nah
I'm disgusting hey don't do that around
the kids actually you know what stay
away from the kids you got music
ladies steer clear the DJ foods to the
right all right hey Chrysler no booze
hey Madison no husband
killing it be man killing it
hey there
dad in the flesh
I see I haven't given up trying to learn
how to barbecue
good for you son well wait what are you
doing here
well I'm not gonna miss my grandkids
sweet 16. it's a big day
right
not gonna flip them yet huh
huh
that might be that's okay it's okay
really well
I just don't want you to mess him up and
other people be disappointed you'll feel
bad they'll be all that uh remember
Bert's barbecue those Burgers
oh see did you add eggs in the mix okay
Dad it binds it moisturizes makes a much
better burger oh my dad showed up from
Florida and it took about two seconds
before he started making me mental with
the
he's a monster oh oh okay yeah breathe
it out there champ okay
yes yeah no the dog's pooping in the
pool what
wait how
how paid money to see my son take off
his shirt and tell his made-up story
about robbing a train for the million
times it's a true story it's my job okay
and you should get back on stage because
I've seen you only like five times you
paid to see him five times
I'm just shocked that people would
actually do that yeah
don't buy Carpet five times
oh sweetheart I'm sorry I'm gonna go oh
don't worry about that and you remember
you can call me anytime whenever you
want to talk about well you know
okay
where are you going hold on Mr Chrysler
hey stop where are you going Matt's
asking me to go to bigger for like three
days oh you are not going anywhere hey
you're 16 years old and you're not going
to Big Bear so I know you're going to
drink beer smoke pot I'll be fine
because I'm not you okay okay stop that
that's fair that's fair I deserve that I
deserve that okay
hey look at me look at me don't go we
wrap up this party me and you hang out
tonight with my such a pimple popper
I don't even watch that show anymore dad
and I don't even know half of these
people here were you kidding me you know
what about this guy you know this guy
Ray Ray you know Ray Ray I said I wanted
a small party and you promised that you
wouldn't embarrass me
it's trying to be a good dad
what about you it's always about you
what are you talking about how did I
make it how did you flip that don't do
that don't leave don't you flip me off
don't you get out of the car don't get
sick see this is a fever Behavior I was
telling you about the therapy
foreign
not now dad
uh
you know
if you're searching for A New Path
there's always room for you with
Chrysler carpets
I'm good dad okay I'm good I promise
just give me a minute
I just wasn't sure you know
hey you're making money if you
I'm doing the whole comedy thing anymore
hey I'm a grown man
I'll figure it out okay all right all
right you know
just trying to help oh hold on right
there no you're not you're never trying
to help Dad that's the point when I got
in trouble what did you say to me oh
don't be an idiot my advice to you was
don't do stupid things in public
especially with the children which is
good advice and you and Sasha wouldn't
be where you were if you'd only listen
to me
ma'am the party's outside okay are you
the machine
yeah I am and I can do a picture in a
second I'm kind of having a private
moment with my father okay
I'm here for the pocket watch
stolen on a train in Russia 23 years ago
by you
okay
I'm having a show day so this is some
sort of tick tock prank I'm about to
lose my
oh
only a prime clearly that's a fake gun
or not she's got a goddamn yeah I'm
clear on that note down yes ma'am my
name is Irina ivanon
and I suggest you start remembering
I was 20 years ago I barely remember
that trip I don't have a watch and it's
definitely not here now you're coming
with me back to Russia to find them
look at your daughter
how innocent
so pure
so vulnerable
do you see that man
DJ chemo you will follow her on Earth
do not find my watch he kills
if you try to run
he kills her
is a word about this to anyone
he kills her okay okay I'll do whatever
you want just just
listen I'll do whatever you want
just don't hurt my daughter and I let my
father go all right he wasn't supposed
to be here he wasn't even invited
I'm going with you Dad you're not going
with me you wouldn't be able to live
with myself if you fail to protect Sasha
dad stop you're not going he goes
if you need persuading in Russia
he might be useful
for torture
the car is waiting we live now
excuse me hit Albert
a
oh my God I haven't seen it yet I'm so
sorry I haven't said hi hello dear
here
hi oh who's this uh this is our uh our
Uber driver uh Sylvia Sylvia
hi
hi your Uber driver where are you going
um
oh my God
yeah I see what's going on you two are
gonna follow Sasha to Big Bear exactly
Big Bear yes cool great well you know
what I'll just stay home take care of
everything and the two of you can just
on your creepy little puritanical
I'm sorry you just touched for me yeah
what good work chrishers
this is my body gun
sponge
bullets